to make that decision to receive help
is not a sign of weakness in today's
world more than ever
it is a sign of strength the royal
family isn't exactly pleased with prince
harry discussing their family matters
publicly
i think unfortunately for the royal
family it seems that prince harry is not
afraid
to draw on his own experiences in order
to relay the importance of mental health
and get his message out a source tells
et that relations between the royal
family and the duke of sussex
have been strained over harry's decision
to continue speaking out
about royal family matters the duke of
sussex along with his wife meghan markle
sat down with oprah winfrey in march for
an explosive interview in which they
addressed
everything from feeling trapped to
personal struggles with mental health
and
allegations of racism within the
institution then with the release of the
new apple tv plus series harry
co-created with oprah winfrey the me you
can't see
prince harry reveals megan broke down in
tears before her tell-all interview with
oprah aired over the bullying
allegations made by former close
advisors
during her time as a working royal
something she has strongly denied
i absolutely know that it's the case
that prince harry
is committed to raising awareness about
mental health he has made
this he and megan together have made
this one of their raisons detroit
a source tells et the royal family
remains hurt
and angry as harry continues to speak
about private matters
publicly quote the fact that there have
been several additional interviews
discussing family matters
hasn't helped the situation i think
certainly people over here
are a little disappointed and i think
frustrated as well at hearing prince
harry
indirectly criticize the royal family
which i think is
the interpretation by some over here in
the uk
in the docu-series prince harry recalls
the night that megan actually broke down
crying over the combined effort of the
firm
and the media to smear her i was woken
up in the middle of the night to her
crying in her pillow because she doesn't
want to wake me up
because i'm already carrying too much
that's heartbreaking
i held her we talked she cried and she
cried
and she cried and back in march megan
told oprah that she had
suicidal thoughts while she was pregnant
with their son archie
but harry says she didn't act on those
thoughts for fear of causing her husband
more trauma after he already suffered
the painful death of his mother in 1997
e.t sat down with the docu-series
director dawn porter
and she opened up about harry and
megan's love and support for one another
she has been his number one supporter
and fan and person encouraging him to be
open and honest and
bring his full self to the world i think
that's
what couples do when they really care
for each other they really really want
to help people
despite the internal family rift a
source tells et that prior to the
release of the oprah
interview and the docu-series several
members of the royal family reached out
directly to congratulate megan after she
and harry announced their pregnancy with
baby number two
adding the family was delighted and
there was real happiness for the couple
especially after megan revealed in 2020
that she
suffered a miscarriage over the summer
megan and harry's relationship with the
royal family may be strained but it
seems they're working on
mending and healing last month e.t
confirmed that megan and harry privately
congratulated prince william and his
wife kate middleton
on their milestone 10th wedding
anniversary the brothers were also
seen speaking to one another at their
grandfather prince phillips funeral i
think
like everyone prince harry loves his
family he
has his relationship with his family but
sometimes our families
inadvertently can do things that can be
difficult to to handle so
it's not to say there's not love and
admiration and respect for his family
it's to say i have this experience i
don't want that for my children
i can both say that's not you know
decades a generation later we're going
to do things differently
you